okay well
um hello from
Sunny Phoenix Arizona uh it's about 10
30 a.m here
um I want to first thank Antonio Baines
I'm the organizing committee
for allowing me the opportunity to give
this presentation
um it's a good thing I'm not traveling
right now I'm just about to run into a
bunch of travel here in the next couple
weeks so it's good to be able to do this
from home
or for my office here TJ
um a little background so teaching
uh short for the translational genomics
Research Institute
we'll pull the phone a little closer and
make sure you can hear
um
we're founded back in 2003 uh
essentially a relatively
um
relatively large group of individuals
who were at the national Human Genome
Research Institute on the NIH campus in
Bethesda uh got together some ideas
about forming a translational research
program and this was kind of before the
word translational was even a buzzword
really trying to
form a Nexus between uh sort of you know
what was happening in the field of
genomics at the time and uh and what was
happening in the clinic at the time as
we were starting to see the development
of more and more targeted therapies
um primarily in the area of cancer but
in other disease systems as well
um and so we all moved out here in
Arizona Phoenix Arizona about 2003 to
set the Institute up we are currently in
our 11th or 12th year
um of existence and things are actually
going pretty well for us uh challenges
just like everyone else has
um but all in all things are going uh
incredibly well for us these are very
exciting times in the field of of
genomics medicine and uh we're we're
glad to be a part of it and kind of feel
that like we are participating in Star
as thought leaders way out in the uh
fringes
um uh of of this per this this uh
burgeoning field
um so the title of my talk
um is
bringing genomics to clinical Cancer
Care uh the promise and the challenges
towards Improvement in clinical
management of patients with cancer uh
and I'm proud to be able to present this
on behalf of all of my uh wonderful
colleagues both in the laboratory again
in the clinic
um I guess before I get started I just
wanted to sort of walk you through a
general outline um I'll probably start
off with some slides that sort of um lay
the groundwork and framework for the
rationale behind why we're doing what it
is we're doing why we think it's
important
um how we got here
um and then uh move into some of the
technical aspects of the methodologies
and techniques that we're using on some
of the background behind those and then
talk a little bit about moving those
methods and techniques into a clinical
setting
I'll call it the laboratory CLIA Labs uh
and and the validation of of these types
of tests and then walk you through some
examples of how we utilize this platform
that we built out here
um to support
uh uh our efforts in in clinical genome
Sciences again primarily in the area of
cancer
um and uh so hopefully by the end of the
presentation you'll have gotten a little
bit of a background on the subject some
real life case studies and examples of
how we're moving these things forward
and utilizing them and then I'll end
with a few slides on you know some of
the things uh additional considerations
that need to be uh uh um sort of uh kept
uh in in mind as we continue to move
forward uh uh with this uh with these
Technologies in the clinic
also forgive me if I'm sneezing and
snorting and coughing because I'm I'm
kind of in the uh uh for at the kind of
late mid stages of a pretty nasty upper
respiratory tract thing that was part
bacterial part viral and so I'm just
trying to get over that so
um uh pardon me if uh make sure if you
can't hear me clearly just let me a note
now I'll try to get closer to the phone
so you know this this slide is pretty
simple but I think it's important and
and sort of recognizing the fact that
cancer at its most basic uh in its most
basic form is a genetic disease
um in many cases there's some intrinsic
or extrinsic Factor it causes a
molecular assault usually genetically
um uh at the DNA level which leads the
cell from being normal and pushing it
down the neoplastic pathway
um some of the intrinsic factors we can
think about are inherited mutations
and genetic predisposition I'm sure
there are probably some people in the
audience who spend quite a bit of their
time studying those types of of
um
uh subjects whether it be genetic
epidemiology uh or uh hereditary
cancer research
and then just general aging we know that
there are some uh there have been a
number of studies in the past it shows
that there are just some general aspects
of Aging that might be related to the
development of cancer although many of
those things are not necessarily all
that clear
um extrinsic factors of course are many
of the neural carcinogens you can think
about
um the chemicals
and that are used in the production of
of cigarettes
um UV irradiation exposure uh and
viruses uh like HPV and hepatitis that
we know uh predisposed to uh various
forms of cancer
um so the discovery of genes that are
altered during the tumor uh tumor tumor
Genesis Pathways led us to new and
better understanding of the driving
forces behind cancer and it's provided
human uh ideas
for treating this disease
and some of the questions that are
important I think from a health
disparities perspective are some of
these uh differences in population and
statistic driving biology that impacts
disease incidents and outcomes
um and and I think we're starting to see
uh some interesting studies come out
that are showing I think both sides of
this from a health disparities aspect my
talk will be focused on disparities but
I think it's important to bring that
aspect up that we're starting to see
studies
that are showing
um uh that biology may not necessarily
be behind certain disparities uh and in
I think one in particular would be
multiple myeloma I'm not going to talk
about that but we've done a lot of work
in that in that uh disease space
um where we show that you know
historically African Americans have had
higher incidence rates and higher
mortality rates than uh whites however
what we've done is we've performed a
deep molecular profiling on multiple
myeloma tumors from African-American and
European patients and show that there
really aren't very many differences and
when we look at some of the indices uh
molecular indices that might Define a
high risk patient or patient who likely
have a disease that will relapse and um
and come back with those Vengeance after
therapy we're seeing that those profiles
are not enriched in African-Americans or
or individuals of recent West African
descent and now that we're seeing better
drugs being developed for this disease
like the image and the proteasome
inhibitors we're actually starting to
see better outcomes in African Americans
on because we have better drugs
so from my standpoint myeloma is a great
example where the biological differences
are not driving the mortality have not
driven the mortality differences it was
accessed uh better drugs and and better
treatments for that disease and better
distribution of those those those
therapies
um and treatment options
think on the flip side of that coin is a
disease like a pediatric alll
acute lymphoblastic leukemia Jun Yang at
um uh I think Jude performed a really
beautiful study was published in nature
genetics uh where he he performed a
genome-wide Association studies on a
large series of children with all and
then he performed principal components
analysis to essentially group
individuals by their genetic ancestry
and what he was able to show was that
children who had greater than 10 percent
Native American ancestry tended to be
diagnosed with a disease that was much
more likely to relapse after treatment
much more likely and the kids had much
much higher uh mortality rates however
he was able to show that if he hit gave
those kids a more intense dose of
chemotherapy which is called uh um
delayed intensification that you could
essentially remove the disparity and so
again in that case for how biology was
playing a role and the outcomes however
you can eliminate that disparity by
giving the kids the appropriate
treatment so again I think that we're
learning more about biology and its role
in cancer Health disparities
um and although my talk won't be focused
on disparities I thought it was
important to sort of lay that groundwork
in that framework um as as I move
forward through my presentation
um there are essentially two major
classes of cancer genes that that I'll
be talking about today
um there are some other classes like
Gatekeepers and but I'm going to focus
on two classes one of the onca genes and
oncogenes are uh genes that when they
are activated abnormally or uh um
produced at levels higher than they
should be in a particular cellular
context uh that activation of that Gene
will lead I'll sail down in neoplastic
pathway some of the well-known octogenes
that some of you might have heard of or
PS3 kinase akt uh mtor Kraft egfr many
of the receptor tyrosine kinases also
fall into the uh a class of broncogenes
and these genes become activated
um and their activation uh can be
associated with cellular transformation
and the onset of tumor Genesis and
cancer
the other and and one way to look at and
these are sort of cartoons is Bianca
genes would be indicative of the
accelerator in a car so of course there
are two ways to make a car go out of
control one is to stick the accelerator
to the floor abnormally
um uh and uh and that's the oncogene
it's like the accelerator the other is
the tumor suppressor the tumor
suppressor is like the brakes um tumor
suppressors are genes that when turned
on typically tell a cell to stop
proliferating stop growing stop
surviving and if you lose that
particular signal the cell doesn't know
when to stop growing or when to stop
proliferating or when to stop surviving
uh and so these are the tumor
suppressors they're like the break so
again you can cut the brake line as a
second mechanism to make a car go out of
control
interestingly many cancer genes will
have both of these particular mechanisms
are
occurring so you will have the tumor
suppressor that um it's like cutting the
brake line and then you'll have the
accelerator stuck to the floor where you
have an activated oncogene and those two
signals can send the cell really fast
down the neoplastic pathway now on
neoplastic Highway
um
I think it's also important to note that
in some instances it may only take one
event I think cancer is a is a process
so there's normal in in many cases
there's sort of a a next step of sort of
premalignant lesion
um and and then that particular
premalignant lesion then has a
propensity to become malignant and so
many tumor types and you've seen the
progression paths where you go from
normal to pre-malignant to malignant you
can think about colon cancer normal uh
colon epithelium to adenomas or polyps
to adenomas to adenocarcinomas
um a multiple myeloma you have normal
plasma cells you have monoclonal
gammopathy of undetermined significance
or M gusts then you have smoldering
myeloma and then you have full-blown
muscle so many Cancers and then
different events or genetic events occur
along that pathway that jump make a cell
jump from one particular step to the
next also the problem is important it um
provide that context
we've learned a lot about the genes and
the proteins
that are involved in cancer and through
that knowledge have also gained you know
considerable in-depth understanding of
how these particular molecules play
together within a cell
and as complicated as a slide like this
may look which is the uh uh CAD cancer
pathway this is probably a super
oversimplification of things but it at
least provides some
a a standard
understanding and framework of the
events that can occur we have the
receptor tyrosine kinases we have some
of the important signaling components
such as the akt pathway pf3 kinase akm
tour pathway of the rasrath Mac Earth
pathway we also have cell cycle
apoptosis with signaling there are a lot
of these Pathways and networks that when
they become perturbed if one uh
alteration occurs essentially sends a
signaling path
um to tell that that sort of abrogates
the normal signaling and and that
collection of events is what causes a a
normal cell to move begin moving down
the neoplastic pathway
um so again although we've learned a lot
we still have a long ways to go there
are a lot of holes and gaps in in our
understanding of how these different
proteins interact with each other
um uh in a normal context or or in a an
abnormal context such as um such as
cancer
um it's also important to know that you
know we understand those genes we've
also learned a lot about how those genes
can become perturbed or altered in
cancer
and it's important to note that
um different alterations can occur in
these genes that can sort of provide uh
um a context for for cancer whether it
be a gene like
uh egfr I mean I'm sorry her2 new which
is Amplified and overexpressed in a
particular some type of breast cancer on
the estrogen receptor can be
overexpressed or mutated uh or be
involved in oncogenic fusions
um egfr
it'd be Amplified it can be mutated or
overexpressed in certain forms of lung
cancer Kraft we know that probably 99 of
pancreatic cancers contain a mutation in
the k-ras oncogene which is its primary
oncogenic signal
um a lot of work has been done our group
found oncogenic fusions and uh the fgfr2
Gene and cholangio metastatic
cholangiocarcinoma and again many of
these are the onca genes that are
perturbing cancer just a subset and then
some of the tumor suppressors that are
altered in in cancer that can include P
53 P10 or B uh cdk into a or p16 and
these genes are typically deleted or
mutated or their promoter region is
hypermethylated which can also lead to
uh inactivation or again cutting of the
brake line and then there are certain
genes that are involved in fusions where
chromosomes will break apart and fused
together abnormally and then the the
fusion
region between uh forms a a chimeric
protein or chimeric Gene product and
protein product uh one of the more
famous would be BCR able uh which is the
uh uh result of the Philadelphia
chromosome and Leukemia uh Temperance
ERG fusions that are very common and
frequent in prostate cancer and the EML
for out translocations and oncogenic
fusions that occur uh in a subset of
about five percent of patients with
non-slaught cell lung cancer which is
also a known oncogenic event
um previously
um it's it was important that you know
we had to have multiple Technologies in
order to identify these these events for
instance to identify the her2 uh uh
amplifications and and breast cancer
it's it's uh IHC which is uh
immunohistochemistry
um which is performed in a Pathology Lab
many times with egfr it's Amplified we
can identify this at the DNA level using
microarrays over expressed at the RNA
level again using RNA microarrays or
mutated and previously we've used things
like Sanger sequencing systems capillary
sequencing uh pyro sequencing identify
these mutations uh again whether they're
mutations and oncogenes or or in in
tumor suppressors
um but uh probably about six or seven
years ago we saw the development
uh and introduction of new uh Next
Generation sequencing technologies that
have really uh provided the opportunity
for us to make all of these multiple
measurements using a single system and
so they've sort of
um uh laid the groundwork for us to be
able to perform very very deep molecular
profiling of tumors
um uh uh using a single experiment
foreign
the appropriate measurements and without
going in
too deep
um one of the the one way to look at it
is
The genome consists of about three
billion
um uh base pairs or letters and just to
put this in context one sheet of paper
you can get about 5 000 letters on it
which equates to one ream being about
2.5 million letters a box of paper is
about
uh 25 uh million letters and you need
about 120 boxes of paper to get to three
billion letters and I think that's about
the height of the uh uh the National
Monument or something I don't know
um but the other important thing is that
in order for us to deal with some of the
error rates that can occur because of
the chemistry and the mathematical
modeling that's um that takes place for
genome sequencing is that we have to
shred it into small pieces uh and then
we have to over sample to overcome
errors so
um we don't want to just look at three
million we want to look at uh through
building we don't want to look at three
billion probably times a hundred
um uh uh so so just think about the
amount of information that has to be
generated
uh using these particular technology but
it's great because we have incredible
Computing now
um much better storage faster uh
processing uh that allows us to not only
generate this particular information but
to analyze it effectively and
efficiently as well so we take each one
of these fragments we shred it into
pieces and then we find usually about 50
to base 100 bases in length and then we
say where does this 100 basis map what's
the highest probability in the genome
for this 100 basis to map and that's how
we map these reads across the genome
another way to look at it is
um it's it's taking one piece of DNA
that's let's say about four or 500
nucleotides in length and we only
sequence the two ends of it
um and so these this sort of represents
a sort of a pile up of what we call
paired ends so one read would be here
its pair would be here
now we don't have the sequence in the
middle but the the computational aspects
allows us to know that this sequence
pairs with this sequence and they should
be about three or four hundred bases
away from each other and on average
that's what you would get so each pair
would map
um and uh there would be the space in
the middle and then as you power these
up along the region you can begin to
sort of collect the information so that
each base is represented multiple times
by this data
and the other important thing is that if
the if these two ends map to different
chromosomes it would also mean that
somewhere in this region of the genome
there's a break point that has occurred
and if you have multiple reads that give
evidence for that break point then that
would suggest that you have perhaps a
translocation or some type of uh uh
genetic or genomic alteration uh uh
that's occurring between or within that
particular region of the genome and so
not only can we get the information on
faces uh the base content of the of of
each read we can also get information on
structural content
um also if we know how many times can be
sequenced or how much data we generated
we can also determine how much genetic
material is present in that region of
the genome cancers can amplify regions
to make more of a gene product or they
can delete regions
um to to cut out a tumor suppressor to
like cut the brake line again and so
using this one technology we can get so
much different uh so many different
pieces of information again we can
identify the mutations at the base level
across the genome we can um uh deduce
copy number changes so amplifications
and deletions across the genome and we
again we can also identify these
rearrangements and translocations and
inversions that can occur uh within a
um a cancer genome
and importantly if we collect RNA from
the cells we can also look at the gene
expression profile uh not only like
microarrays just looking at one probe
but we actually get the base information
of the RNA as well so we can get
incredible in-depth high resolution uh
genetic information using these
Technologies in a way that we were never
able to do let's say five to ten years
ago so these Technologies provide a
comprehensive framework for genomic
interrogation again in a single
experiment so if I have normal DNA and
tumor DNA from a patient and I collect
RNA from the tumor in that one sequence
run I can sequence the entire genome
identify all the mutations all the copy
number changes all the structural events
and perform gene expression at the base
level the Exon level the isoform level
level and identify oncogenic fusions of
a single experiment
so because of the power power of these
Technologies we're now able to ask a
relatively pointed question uh and as we
continue to see you know additional
development of the pharmaceutical
community
as relates to targeted therapies where
we have different tumor types and we
have specific genetic alterations uh and
the development of drugs that Target
those alterations again uh B rap v600e
mutation that occurs in melanoma
um uh uh is a biomarker for the drug the
morafynib
hurts and new and the use of the drug
testing the map or perceptin and her two
new positive breast cancers the use of
the drug and matineb or Gleevec for the
use of BCR able uh Fusion uh positive
leukemias t-gen has played a role in
some of these the development of
proteosome Inhibitors with our partners
of the Mayo Clinic in Scottsdale and
activation of NFS half of three pathway
as well as the development of mesmo to
give which is a hedgehog inhibitor for
patients with metastatic basal cell
carcinoma particularly particularly
those that have uh past mutations so as
we see you know uh continued development
of specific targeted Therapeutics around
very specific genomic alterations we can
begin to utilize these next Generation
sequencing Technologies to ask the
question is molecular profile and
actually a rational approach to increase
the options available to oncologists for
treating cancer patients so instead of
you know once a cancer patient has
failed standard of care
um and uh the the uh perhaps failed
standard of Care at relapse the dots
pretty much on the oncologists have a
dilemma where they have to sort of think
about what's the next option for that
patient
um in many cases
the the standard of care is not related
to a specific Target of therapy although
we were starting to see some of that uh
beginning to increase over time with
more and more of these treatments
um I think the the other part of that is
now have better Technologies more
sensitive and specific Technologies and
biomarker development
but once a patient feels uh standard of
care and diagnosis and standard of care
relapse the docs then have the
opportunity to utilize political trials
um and you know
you know to be honest a lot of times
they aren't armed with enough
information to determine what might be
the best particular treatment option for
that patient at that particular point in
time and so perhaps if we can provide
them with very specific molecular
information against a particular tumor
that can perhaps provide a doctor with
key insights to determine what might be
an appropriate therapy to use in that in
that advanced setting now I will preface
these comments by saying there's still a
lot of complications in our
understanding uh maybe at the end of
this I'll get some questions about the
the word heterogeneity on clonality it
comes up time and time and time again so
you think about a patient with a patient
with Advanced cancer
in many cases there's not just one tumor
cell clonal tumor cell that's uh
propagating throughout the patient there
are multiple tumor cells in a lot of
instance there is a probably a single
primary clone that gave rise to the
patients uh uh uh full-blown cancer but
each one of those cancer cells is
continually divide divide and propagate
and collect new mutations right
um and so when you think about that
you know we're we're we're we're we're
we we need to try our best to address
the entire complement of the cancer in
the patient now we've seen some
interesting studies come out over the
last year or two where individuals have
taken a tumor uh cut it into different
pieces sequenced each of the pieces and
shown that there are different genomic
events in each of those pieces of tumor
we've also seen individuals take
different metastatic lesions from the
same patient and see the same thing
other things that we
that we cases the key driving events are
there in all of the particular uh tumors
within a patient or within a given
lesion for instance you know there's a
P10 homozygous deletion and you see it
everywhere now you might see specific
mutations in each one of those lesions
but all of them have the same P10
deletion or they all have a p16
deletion or they all have a k-ras
mutation so what we want to do is to be
able to see if we can Target those
driving events those quote unquote
driver mutations
um that are probably the mutations that
have given rise to the primary cancer
and are are the primary culprit for
tumor Genesis now there's another class
of mutations that might be associated
with drug resistance
um so there are certain mutations that
can occur that will that that actually
you know if we have knowledge that that
mutation is that means that specific
drugs will not be effective against that
particular tumor so we have to keep that
context in mind as well so so this it's
a very sort of uh complex picture but
you know amazingly we're starting to get
a better a better view of it I don't
won't say that we have a particular high
resolution view of it
um but boy we're starting to see it more
and more clearly day after day we're
learning more and and this is an
iterative process in an iterative system
we learn every time we do a patient and
we can apply that new knowledge on to
the next patient so so with that in mind
I'd like to provide you with sort of the
framework that we've built out for our
uh genomics enabled medicine uh platform
um
and uh this is sort of a an algorithm uh
that just sort of has some pictures and
a a more General diagram of our process
there have been a number of papers that
have been published
um that sort of demonstrate a similar
process there are a number of groups
around the country and around the world
that have developed similar platforms uh
whether it's the group of abroad
Institute washu Baylor uh uh just to
name a few and a number of companies
that have gotten off the ground that are
using these types of technology
to distribute uh this more broadly
across the oncology community in many
cases they'll draw it as more of a
linear
um uh uh process where you go from
patient
um to you know sequencing to a report
um you know but I tend to draw it more
as a cyclical process and I use the word
iterative a minute ago
um meaning that we start with patient
and consent uh and position
and here's the green light goes through
uh uh biopsy uh shipping and collection
collection and shipping of the specimen
a quality assessment of the specimen and
the analytes that are derived of DNA and
RNA are proteins through sequencing uh
data processing and Analysis and then
we've developed a clinical clinical
genomics engine that will take the
genomic information from the tumor match
it to the targeted drug space and then
provide a report that's discussed that
in molecular tumor board which then
provides information or recommendations
to the tree and oncologist based on the
molecular information
and again as I mentioned earlier it's a
it's a cycle it's a it's an iterative
process meaning that when we finish with
patient one we learn and we can apply
that knowledge to Patient two and then
to Patient three and four so although
this can sometimes be framed out as an
end of one study
um it actually over time you've been
begin to collect cohorts and we learn
from the outcome so we want to be able
to follow after treatment how did the
patients do to the patient respond
um if so for how long if the patient
relapses on a new tumor arises can we
collect or get a biopsy from a new tumor
and sequence until we can ask the
question did new mutations arise if the
tumor evolve I've got a particular sub
clue now gain a new um uh growth
advantage to become the dominant clone
that's resistant to the current
therapeutic regimen and so we can
continue to learn from these studies so
that over time this knowledge engine
continues to grow by which the more and
more genomic data we have we we collect
we can match it to you know the the
improved and increased knowledge to make
these uh uh uh reports uh uh as accurate
as possible over time and that's our our
um primary goal is to provide you know
the most accurate uh information uh and
most clinically relevant information to
the oncologist so that they can make
what we feel are more informed decisions
uh as they begin to treat these patients
with these Advanced cancers
so given that we've built this pipeline
out one of the you know important
aspects is that
um if it's going to be used in in
clinical management then it has to you
know fall into the auspices of a
Clinical Laboratory uh and clinical
processes
um I'm going to take a brief time out uh
uh for a little bit of uh just give me a
second I'm struggling here
sorry maybe I should have muted
um
okay uh so what we're dealing with here
are what we would consider uh laboratory
developed tests uh or ldts and I've
bolded that for a reason you know there
was this sort of I know these are CMEs
and there are some questions that that
are going to be asked and
I bolded a few things uh some of my some
of you might want to keep that in mind
um
um so the laboratory developed test
um is a test that's performed in a
Clinical Laboratory uh in many cases
it's what we call a home brew which
means that you've developed a very
specific test to make it very specific
measurement
which means you have to meet us a
certain series of uh validation metrics
um it's also important to note that you
know we all we all hear this this word
biomarker quite a bit
um
and what we're dealing with here there
are two different classes of biomarkers
uh if you talk to anyone involved in The
Clinical Laboratory space there's the
integral biomarker and the integrated
biomarker
um in the case of an integral this is
where the data is actually going to be
used for clinical management so in a
clinical trial you screen tumors and
patients for a particular mutation uh
and if they have the mutation the
patients get treated because of that
mutation that is an integral biomarker
whereas by which an integrated biomarker
is where you're doing more Discovery
where you're you're treating patients
all of the patients with a drug you're
collecting tumors you profile and you're
looking for differences uh in response
so the patients that respond versus the
ones that don't respond is there a
molecular signature of response that's
more of an integrated biomarker where
that information is not necessarily
going to be used to determine how to
treat the patient but you still want to
collect information from the development
of a particular biomarker Downstream so
that's the integrated so what we're
dealing with here are the integral
biomarkers where we're using molecular
information that will actually
um uh uh be the integral to the clinical
decisions that are made by the the doc
so you know there's you know two types
of validation I also think that's
important
um specifically there's technical slash
analytical
um and I'm going to put a slash here
instead of and
um technical flash analytical validation
and this is actually uh required and
regulated by CMS or the centers for
Medicare Medicaid services uh and CLIA
which is the Clinical Laboratory
Improvement uh Amendments of 1988.
um and so they actually regulate
um uh Clinic uh technical or analytical
validation of a particular laboratory
developed test
however clinical validation or the
clinical validity of a test is actually
regulated by the Food and Drug
Administration or the FDA now more
recently the FDA uh have gotten more
involved and they actually want to be
involved in the regulation of some of
the uh Technical and analytical
validation as well and if you want to
develop a molecular device or have a
real FDA validated biomarker you
actually have to provide information on
your Technical and analytical validation
and it has to be done by their
particular requirements and regulations
on that is the FDA but in general
laboratory develop tests are are
regulated by CMS and CLIA
and for these technical slash analytical
validations
um you have to um develop a test and
validate it and that validation process
must provide information on the
reproducibility repeatability
sensitivity specificity precision and
accuracy for detecting or making a
particular measurement and in our case
it's identifying somatic events in a
tumor somatic mean tumor specific uh
alteration so the alterations that have
Arisen in the tumor we're trying to make
those measurements identify the
amplifications lesions mutations
structural rearrangements or gene
expression uh differences that have
occurred in the tumor and we have had to
develop a validation uh plan and execute
that plan in order to uh show
reproducibility repeatability
sensitivity specificity precision and
accuracy for that particular test
and we've
um had to use a series of cell lines and
normal tumor pairs uh uh of the type
that uh for the tests that we're making
um and I'll talk a little bit about that
later and for both DNA and RNA uh and on
the DNA level it's mutations copy number
changes uh structural events uh and uh
determine for instance sensitivity we
did dilution studies where we took tumor
and normal DNA and we diluted them at
different
um uh uh titrations to see how far can
we go down in tumor content genome
content to identify a particular genomic
event like a deletion or a mutation at
the RNA level we compared the RNA
sequencing data from uh validation
samples against appymetrics gene
expression data that have been generated
in another clear lab to look at the
correlation coefficients at how well do
we match up with that acid data uh and
use that as information uh uh uh for
accuracy see of our RNA laboratory and
our pipeline
um
interestingly we also one of the the
common events that occur in cancer are
oncogenic fusions at the RNA level I
mentioned those VCR able to preserve
um EML for out and so in order to
validate that we actually just published
a paper recently
um where we developed a series of
synthetic oligos spykins that
recapitulate known uh oncogenic fusions
uh like ews uh atf-1 occur in u.sarcoma
ew ews fleas also occurs in Ewing's on
the ml4 Oz BS are able a bunch of known
oncogenes who created long
oligosynthetics condiment to an in vitro
transcription Vector main RNA and then
spiked it into cell line DNA so we could
really study
how well we can identify uh oncogenic
fusions as our as our validation uh we
determine uh Precision against a series
of different uh um uh analysis pipelines
using different Fusion detection
algorithms uh and and generated a series
of graphs that you know look at
different fusions
um uh and and using you know different
dilutions of diffusion in the cell line
RNA how well do we identify those
fusions and interestingly we use three
different uh Fusion detection algorithms
and interestingly if you look here at
Temperance uh etv1 you can see that only
one of the three fusion detection
algorithms pick that Fusion up uh and
then here if you look at eml4 out
um one of the missed completely
regardless of dilution level so we were
able to test different algorithms
different dilutions to really validate
our ability to identify oncogenic
fusions
um uh uh and as part of our validation
so uh in the development of this
Clinical Laboratory we also had to
develop a series of standard operating
procedures or Sops such as uh laboratory
quality assurance specimen accessioning
so receiving samples of putting them
into a laboratory information management
system that's under uh um that's running
under the offices of of HIPAA to ensure
privacy uh um uh uh histopathological
tissue qualification of the specimens
analyte extraction and qualification
analytes being DNA and RNA from Whole
blood from Frozen tissue from paraffin
embedded archival tissue uh we have
several tests that are based on quality
quantitative PCR
uh and our next Generation sequencing
primarily using these platforms uh we
also had to validate our bioinformatics
analysis Pipeline and our reporting so
the report that we generate either a
technical report that gives the
technical uh um uh uh qualifications and
metrics of a particular sequency run and
Analysis or an interpretive report that
actually will match up a series of
mutations with a series of of known uh
uh Therapeutics that are related to that
particular genomic event
and this is just a copy of our our CMS
license for The Clinical Laboratory and
for the FDA this was a document that had
to be submitted to the FDA for our
validation for one of our clinical
trials which is uh a phase two study for
metastatic melanoma patients that have
b-rap v600e negative tumors uh and we're
sequencing the tumor to identify
therapeutically actionable events and
treaty uh based on the molecular profile
of these tumors and this was the the IND
and the IDE documents that had to be
submitted to the FDA for approval to
start that study so it's a lot of work
um we uh at the DNA level wanted for for
a lot of our studies we're taking a very
comprehensive approach uh where we're
taking more of a genome-wide a view of
the genome to capture all of the
structural events and to deeply assess
the coding regions around the exons
um to identify mutations with high
levels of sensitivity and specificity uh
and also uh uh uh mRNA sequencing so
we're really focusing on the messenger
rnas because currently right now uh most
of the therapeutically relevant
information is coming from the messenger
rnas although we know that there's a lot
of work on going with micro rnas and
long non-coding rnas but currently those
are not as clinically relevant but I
think over the next five to ten years
they might be so right now we're just
focusing on the MRNA
um again using you know really high
resolution fast sequencing this
particular system will uh generate a
very comprehensive genome and our and
whole transcriptome quality data in
about 30 hours we have a really amazing
analysis pipeline that was developed by
um Dr David Craig and then we have an
amazing computational environment that's
been developed in collaboration with
Dell Computing the process data again we
have our somatic compendium report that
will have the mutations and alterations
that are present in a particular tumor
and we have a drug Gene relationship
database that's been built by uh Jeff
Kiefer and Sarah Byron here at T gen
that matches up all the known uh Pharma
pharmaceutical space and targeted
therapies with their known biomarker
information either general rules or very
specific rules I am in a series of
heuristic algorithms have been put
together
a computationally to match these uh
lists together to generate a report uh
that a clinical report that can be
provided to an oncologist that will have
the drug the uh genomic information
that's relevant in that particular tumor
the indication rather to give the drug
or not given that genomic context and uh
a bunch of ancillary information that we
can provide and we can customize these
reports such that some docs may want to
know whether or not their clinical
trials available for that particular
drug
that their patient can go on
so I want to walk through a series uh
now of and I only have about 15 minutes
late so left so I'm gonna walk through
these pretty quickly
um just some sort of um case studies and
anecdotal uh um
um uh evidence of the process and how
we've used it and and situations where
we've seen some really uh excellent
um uh uh uh uh outcomes and patience and
I guess these could be called
exceptional responders and uh we did a
study in triple negative breast cancer
that was published um about a year ago
so an aggressive type of of breast
cancer that lacks ER PR her2 uh tends to
occur more frequently in young
African-American women and although 70
percent cure thirty percent are chemo
resistant and very very difficult to
treat we know that patients that have
brca2 germline variants
um tend to be diagnosed with these
vasolite triple negative tumors uh and
there's some information suggesting that
Park Inhibitors are affecting in that
setting however there are really no uh
effective treatments for women with
chemo resistant triple negative disease
uh this study was done as a partnership
with Life Technologies and U.S oncology
where we performed whole genome transfer
whole transfer from a sequence of about
14 patients with metastatic triple
negative disease to build or work
through this process and identify
therapeutically relevant uh information
that can be provided to the treated
oncologists
uh again this is published in molecular
our cancer Therapeutics
um one patient in particular was a
patient with metastatic triple negative
we identified a braf uh amplification
at the copy number level and further
deduction of this particular information
showed that it was part of a what we
call a double minute which is
extracellular
um uh a circle that is made up of
different bits and pieces of DNA from
different chromosomes that replicates on
its own and using fish we're able to
show that these weren't in fact double
minute uh and so they're just pumping
out tons of b-wrap so
um our uh report
um indicated braf href and impp4b which
is a tumor suppressor involved in akt
signaling we ended up uh um uh
suggesting or recommending a combination
Mech akt and you can see this is tumor
before and after only two cycles on this
combination there was essentially with
Joyce O'Shaughnessy called the other
worldly response in this particular
tumor
um uh and uh again this is one of those
settings where the patient would never
have gotten this combination of therapy
had we not provided that molecular
context we find this context in quite a
few uh women with breast cancer
metastatic triple negative as well as
many of the metastatic uh ER positives
and we found lots of alterations in
these two Pathways uh raster make earth
pathway uh and the pi3 kinase ak-10 tour
classroom
um another interesting uh series of
observations occurred in metastatic
cholangiocarcinoma the study was
published uh uh uh earlier this year
where we identify several therapeutic
contexts that uh genomic context that
led to uh uh um uh non-uh or relatively
unique therapeutic context that led to
interesting outcomes in these patients
very difficult to treat tumor type one
patient had an inactivated mutation in a
gene called err-fi1
importantly
err-fi1 is a sort of endogenous
inhibitor of egfr signaling so it sort
of binds to the
heterodimerization pocket of her uh her
receptors such as egfr and her2 and
prevents them from down rising and it's
their dimerization that leads to
Activation so if you lose ER if i1 you
get hyperminarization and
hyperactivation of egfr and in this uh
study that was published by a group back
in 2007 in nature they were actually
able to show that
um if you uh uh uh knock out uh e r r f
i one or big six uh you can abrogate uh
egfr phosphorylation and activity and a
series of mutants you uh uh can uh
reverse that so this is a very very
important tool with suppressor that if
lost leads to the activation of egfr
um so the tuber board discussion was to
use using egfr inhibitor and lo and
behold this is tumor before tumor after
60 reduction uh in tumor after only two
or three Cycles on an egfr inhibitor
again this patient would never have
gotten this drug had the doc not have
that genomic information uh this is sort
of a metabolic activity looking at that
tumor this is before this is after so
they're shutting down the tumor activity
uh almost completely
we also found a novel uh oncogenic
fusions and translocations that include
the fgfr2 oncogene and three different
uh metastatic cholangiocarcinoma
patients
um at the time there were a series of
fgfr Inhibitors being
moving through therapeutic development
one that was pretty close to FDA
approval was posappanib
um uh in these patients we went for fgfr
uh inhibitors
and um sorry this is uh this should be
uh corrected
um but anyway these patients went on
fgfr Inhibitors this is tumor before you
can see the tumor is pretty much gone
after four months
um this is looking at density metric
measurements of the tumor before uh this
is after six weeks on on finite you can
see that the tumor is pretty much gone
away uh and here's tumor and the tumor
has gone away again on after only six
weeks patient would never have got an
fgfr inhibitor have the doc's not had
that therapeutic contract
and so we're um seeing a bunch of Trials
starting to open up and we're hoping to
work on one ourselves and have some
proposals and and and The Works to uh
look at this disease and I think it's
important because we know that
um metastatic cholangia carcinoma is a
health disparity it's very it's much
more common in African Americans uh and
so I would love to interrogate a series
of tumors and African-American patients
uh to see if these uh genomic contacts
are are are there and if so perhaps we
can find a way to treat these pretty
nasty to us
um lastly I want to talk about a um a
young lady who happened to be diagnosed
with neuroblastoma a really young girl
this is a pediatric setting uh she
happened to be African-American uh we
sequenced her tumor and these tumors
typically commonly have uh in this is a
neuroblastoma they typically have inmate
amplification or mutations in F this
patient did not have inmate
amplification and did not have an alph
mutation but we did find a rearrangement
in a gene called pcprd which is a tumor
suppressor
um and here are some of the discordant
repairs that are defining this uh uh
weird uh structural event occurring in
pcprd
importantly pcprd inactivates the uh
Aurora kinaseonka Gene and Aurora kinase
activation is very important for endning
stabilization so this was an interesting
context in that it this possibly was
leading to inmix stabilization without
inmate amplification
and so one way to look at this is
phosphorylated Aurora kinase leads to
stabilize and make which leads to
tumorogenesis and there is a known
Aurora kinase inhibitor that was in
development by the of uh pharmaceutical
company millennium and so one would
think if you could abrogate
phosphorylation using this particular
inhibitor
um you could it would lead to
um uh a reduction in tumor and possibly
a response from this patient
the patient did go on this drug we're
able to get the drug through
compassionate use and uh some animal
models had shown that if we use this
drug in certain um pediatric tumor mouth
models that you could get a very
significant tumor reduction uh and
increase in uh survival in these animals
and uh so the tumor board suggested the
use of this orokinase inhibitor she did
get the drug and she is having having a
great response I was trying to get some
images from my colleague at Children's
Hospital of Orange County but couldn't
but it's just an amazing story where
this young lady had a really nasty tumor
and she's on a drug that she would never
have gotten and she's doing well so
we're really excited about that one
um so uh you know sort of just wrapping
up I think it's important again you know
CMS clear FDA requirements and guiding
principles uh driving the development of
these ldts and um you know we have to
keep in mind the difference between the
technical versus clinical validations
um uh also clinical trials uh using FDA
approved and or investigational agents
one of the important aspects for our
Gene drug relationship database is the
act is the actual pharmacopoeia that's
we're using some docs can only use FDA
approved drugs so we we have to use a
database uh um uh where our
pharmacopoeia is selected only around if
you approved drugs well whereas other
trials like our uh stand up to cancer
melanoma study we're using
investigational agents as well as part
of our pharmacopoeia so that all has to
be taken into context uh the important
other important aspect is access to
these pharmaceutical agents and we're
seeing a lot more uh sort of
compassionate use where we have a great
context
uh there's no clinical trial but we
believe that a particular company has a
drug that would work great in that
context the docs can write the company
and ask for Access and it just really
depends on where the drug is in the
pipeline where the drug is and it's FDA
approval process I'm we're seeing more
and more we're getting access one of the
big issues is combinations right many of
these tumors have more than one mutation
and we need to hit multiple Pathways
rasrath maker pr3 kinase akt
um and uh these combinations are tough
sometimes because of toxicities and a
lot of times there has to be at least a
phase one dosing study that's been
completed to know what the minimum
tolerated dose for these combinations is
uh uh and so we have to you know we're
working through these combinations
one way to help us is the use of a
patient derived xenograph models where
we take a biopsy from the patient
implanted into an animal and now we have
the tumor growing in animals then we can
test these combinations on the tumor and
the animal model and ask whether or not
that combination is very effective
against that tumor and then perhaps we
can work towards moving into a clinical
trial for that combination and lastly
and I won't get too deep into this but
this is a biggie which is reimbursement
how do we get this paid for are the
companies going to provide some of these
drugs uh compassionate use without
without cost uh if if it can be paid for
will the insurance pay for it what are
the mechanisms by which we we can get
the reimbursement
um what evidence is required by the the
in the insurance company uh in order to
to to to get access to reimbursement so
that's a big issue that we're trying to
work towards
um as it relates to
um continually pushing these things
towards uh more uh Broad and widespread
distribution and so finally you know
another big question is are we going to
be able to sort of retrofit this type of
high complexity testing into the current
uh clinical Paradigm or
are we gonna have to rethink the whole
thing uh including how we do the testing
how we do drug development how we design
clinical trials how we educate the
greater uh Medical Professional
Community
um how we measure outcomes and
standardize the nomenclature and the
elect and the clinical lexicon
um uh the uh whole aspects of
reimbursement and then education for
patient and and community outreach so uh
in closing you know the promise of these
Technologies is to deliver deliver the
most appropriate and uh uh uh accurate
um uh drug information uh based on tumor
profiles to get hopefully get to the
most uh effective outcomes uh and and
and best outcomes and uh but there are a
lot of challenges that remain and so one
of which is will this approach lead to
improved outcomes and Effectiveness
without sacrificing efficiency to the
current Health Care Systems and making
sure these Technologies in successful
are affordable uh broadly distributed
and available to all patients so with
that I'll close and put up a an
acknowledgment slide uh key
acknowledgment is Dr David Craig who's
uh uh Chief bioinformatician here and uh
deputy director of information Sciences
who's just been incredible my sort of
partner in crime and developing this
platform uh our CLIA laboratory group
um uh some of our collaborators and
Industry and our clinical collaborators
at Mayo Scottsdale Healthcare carmanos
and I put in the Pediatric case at the
last minute and I'd also like to
um uh um uh uh acknowledge Lenny Cinder
at Children's Hospital Orange County so
with that I'll stop and uh I think
either of a minute or two to answer a
few questions I'll hang around I do have
to run off on a phone call in a minute
but I can hang around and answer a few
questions so thanks
all right
hello
foreign